hey by the way we should mention and
this is a good lesson for everyone that
on your new Netflix special it's called
time machine Leslie Jones watch it it's
funny you got the guys who direct and
write the game of Thrones I actually did
not think they was gonna say yes
why would you think to get the guy who
directed I mean would I want someone who
was from a comedy but I need some no
have you ever heard this when I worked
at Denny's right they loved me because I
didn't know how to waitress they could
teach me how to waitress yes I don't
want someone who knows about comedy
because then you have to unknot like
there that's not what the [ __ ] I do this
is what the [ __ ] I do so now you you get
people who know how to direct action
because I'm very action and yes you're a
very physical commitment that the faces
you make sometimes did you practice
those faces in the mirror when I first
started comedy I hearse two hours a day
two hours a day people knew not to [ __ ]
with me doing my rehearsal time where
would you do this and at my house I
would rehearse in front of mirror mirror
times
cuz Lucille Ball Carol Burnett moms
Mabley you know all of them got faced
moms Mabley had babies face it but you
need to understand what I'm saying face
I mean being able to get across what
you're saying without saying a [ __ ]
word Lucille Ball did it all the time
yeah you take a big pauses in your
stand-up and you start to get physical
and act you'll strut across it's like
John Ritter you know like dat action
show you would stare in a mirror I'm
staring a mirror so I can know what
everybody else is seeing and in fact
it's Saturday Night Live they used to
call it the Leslie look right they would
write it in two scripts yeah sometimes
they didn't know what to write down they
say just the Leslie look they just
Leslie look so I got that from my
brother they shot the special very well
by the way beautiful how many cameras
nine nine they fought for dying cameras
so that's a big budget for a reason that
I wanted them to yeah
Time Machine you gotta see it I've seen
her live but she and you I'll tell you
what I feel the film really did capture
you your live performance I compared it
to what I had seen and it was Leslie
you look fabulous and they captured your
physicality you did a great it just
showed that I'm a real comic